[Música]
y yo que el momento de revista de prensa
en directo américa de france 24 por
supuesto ya está conmigo en el estudio
de rosa pérez más de rosa bienvenida
pues una mañana bien movida una semana
bien movida en el ámbito noticioso vamos
a dedicar por supuesto esta sección de
revista de prensa el cubrimiento de toda
la prensa internacional de los últimos
avances de la crisis en ucrania
empecemos entonces con los editoriales
del washington post y del país en
españa' buenos días raúl exactamente una
semana movida y sólo estamos a martes a
martes ya yo estoy cansada de
mentalmente bueno pues como decías
empezamos por el editorial del
washington post que se titula así es
como termina el mundo post guerra fría y
asegura no con una explosión ni con un
gemido ni una grito sino con una
diatriba dice en un soliloquio visto en
directo alrededor del mundo putin
deslegitimó no sólo ucrania sino toda la
arquitectura de la seguridad europea y
que su retórica allanó el terreno para
la guerra mientras que el país
titula también unidad ante putin dice
que reconocimiento de las
autoproclamadas repúblicas de don
haskins es un paso inaceptable en el
marco jurídico internacional pero dice
que por otro lado las democracias
occidentales llegan más unidas que en
anteriores ocasiones entre otras cosas
dice porque a diferencia de trump baiden
ha hecho esfuerzos para mantener una
relación estrecha con sus aliados
europeos una pues afirmación matizable
pero que dice mientras rusia actúa y
china observa las democracias deben
mantenerse unidas y con fuerza el rosa
hablando china que titulares de beijing
el 'global times' pues el 'global times'
considera que china no es un número
observador en esta cuestión y hace
referencia a la reunión de urgencia del
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
que se celebró ayer y recuerda que china
hizo un llamado a todas las partes
implicadas en el conflicto a abogar por
una salida pacífica
ahora rosa al margen de china le
pregunto cómo reacciona las autoridades
alrededor del mundo con el
reconocimiento de estas dos regiones
separatistas de ucrania hablamos de
donges por supuesto y lugares como lo
estamos comentando lo vemos con el medio
al yazira exacto este medio qatarí al
yazira hace un repaso de cuáles han sido
las reacciones internacionales y aparte
de estas sanciones promovidas por eeuu
que vamos siguiendo en directo pues
también recalca otras reacciones como la
del presidente de la otan que considera
que pues en el discurso y lo que se
desata de esta retórica de putin es una
violación de los acuerdos
internacionales en el mismo sentido
habló antonio guterres el secretario
general de la onu que dijo que es una
violación de la integridad territorial y
de la soberanía de ucrania no en el
mismo sentido ursula von der leyen
también pues el presidente francés el
presidente de polonia pero también por
ejemplo japón e irán por para destacar
otro otro país dijo que en los
movimientos de la otan han complicado
más aún la situación pero insiste
también en encontrar una salida pacífica
a la situación turquía por ejemplo pidió
a sus ciudadanos que abandonaran el este
de ucrania y australia calificó el
movimiento de moscú de sinsentido eso en
la prensa internacional pero vamos a
enfocarnos rosa en la prensa local que
dicen los medios en ucrania y en rusia
pues nos hemos centrado en dos medios
por un lado el correo internacional y
por otro lado la agencia tass de rusia
que hacen ellos mismos un repaso de
muchos medios locales de la región por
ejemplo el iat este medio ruso pero que
lenin dice que la el discurso de putin
es una decisión histórica y que plantea
una nueva ideología de la política
exterior rusa cita por ejemplo un
economista que dice asistimos al
nacimiento de un mundo post ucraniano
por otro lado el medio con solo mosca ya
pravda dice bueno hace una crónica de
cómo se vivió la situación tras el
discurso en donges habla de fuegos
artificiales
minutos antes de que empezara el 'toque
de queda' militar por otro lado en el
periódico védomosti dice y un politólogo
la casa blanca juega un juego
estableciendo fechas para el inicio de
la guerra y el kremlin juega a otro
juego y es hacer que occidente presione
a ucrania para que implemente los
acuerdos de minsk un sociólogo también
indica en este mismo medio que un
ciudadano medio de rusia no ve un
vínculo directo entre la política
exterior del kremlin y su día a día como
se reseña esto en nuestra región rosa
pues el espectador plantea que viene
ahora no después de este discurso de
putin y de este envío de las tropas ya
de rusas para esta misión ha de mantener
la paz supuestamente y recalca que el
discurso de putin cito textualmente
mostró más que nunca su deseo de
recomponer el imperio ruso y por otro
lado página 12 de argentina
señala que no hubo ni invasión tal y
como había previsto eeuu ni una cumbre
entre biden y putin como había
adelantado el presidente francés sino
que putin jugó una carta que dejó a
occidente sumido en el estupor cerramos
de esta sección con imágenes del mosquit
jaime la evacuación de ciudadanos y el
donbass hacia rusia exactamente porque
el periodista félix like
sigue a refugiados del donbass que se
dirigen al rostov desde el viernes
pasado que empezaron estas evacuaciones
de esta autoproclamada república
independiente pues como decíamos sigue
hacia el otro lado de la frontera hay a
las decenas de cientos de personas que
están haciendo este camino hacia la
frontera rusa porque recordemos además
putin aseguró que va a dar una dotación
de 130 dólares a cada uno de los
exiliados mucha información rosa
posiblemente toda la semana
así es rosa muchísimas gracias entonces
por toda la información mañana más
revista de prensa vamos con eso primer
invitado